donc moi je suis bon par rapport aux
propos de gerald je vais pas rentrer
dedans moi je vais rester dans le
mouvement gilles hérit bien sûr donc moi
oui bien sûr je suis pour la reprise
mais une reprise comme on l'a commencée
retourner au fond demain
depuis le début on a commencé à me
demandant des revendications claires
simples et pas compliqué moi j'étais
venu sur ce plateau j'avais dit quoi
je veux trouver de la justesse pouvoir
travailler être rémunéré manger à crever
la bouche ouverte avec une pelote de
terre dans la bouche tout simplement et
a aujourd'hui personne ne s'en sort
personne donc un moment sinon rien n'a
changé ça doit rien n'a changé on est
resté en fait aux vacances on va dire où
tout le monde est parti en vacances à
retirer un peu son âge il est certes
mais en attendant on ne s'en n'est
arrêté au même endroit est ce que vous
sentez le même élan le même enthousiasme
au tout début du corps enthousiasme
peut-être pas mais par contre la colère
oui
la colère est lié et les gens en ont
marre en ont marre de ce système en ont
marre de ce gouvernement en ont marre de
se faire rouler comme des moutons ça
c'est sûr et c'est une idée vous avez
répondu non vous ne croyez pas au retour
de gilet jaune
oui alors c'est pas vous voulez hein
c'est quoi est ce que vous croyez
je ne crois pas pourquoi parce que je
trouve que les revendications ne sont
pas claires je trouve que le mouvement
est trop radicalisées je trouve que la
violence est trop mise en avant
je trouve qu'il ya trop de casseurs et
pourtant pour moi c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt parce que derrière comme
dit olivier les jours les gens ont faim
en france
j'en connais beaucoup qui dorment dans
leur voiture
j'en connais beaucoup des familles
monoparentales qui souffrent en sciences
j'ai fait des livres là dessus et
malheureusement cette violence exacerbée
cette radicalisation convoi je me
rendais gays sont à lui déjà sur le
plateau de foyers des diarrhées je ne
trouve de plus en plus crispé et puis je
te comprendre qu'une seule journée on ne
va pas seulement votre journée mais
ramos et puis ça que vous avez vécu et
tout et j'ai même pas je cherche même
pas à m'excuser par rapport à la
mutilation dont tu subis j'ai dit une
connerie j'ai dit une connerie j'assume
maintenant un moment donné j'aimerais
juste qu'avant de parler vous puissiez
vous renseigner gers qui ce qu'on
appelle le métier de journaliste
d'accord vous avez aujourd'hui une
plateforme qui s'appelle le vrai débat
vous parlez là il
dendre général parce que j'ai souvent la
question je ne le connais pas
personnellement
prenez le vrai débat point fr vous avez
une plateforme sur lequel un million
plus d'un million de citoyens de france
ont répondu à des questions on est
ressorti sans une revendication précise
sur lesquels ont été extraites 59
revendications encore plus précises
alors qu'il se manifeste je finis juste
manifeste a été déposée dans chaque
ministère
remis en main propre avec accusé de
réception pour ne serait-ce que se faire
entendre
aujourd'hui oui on accélère on est
toujours un effet de loupe sur le
phénomène de violence je vous rejoins et
oui essayer s'il est dans une de vos
émissions chez ces news de mettre un
phénomène de loupe en invitant une
priscilla loudot ski qui va pouvoir vous
étayé l'ensemble des revendications sur
lesquels des groupes de gilet jaune
bosse depuis deux ans je vais vous dire
d'où vient la foule la queue lancerait
venir d'une frustration lance les
casseurs c'est ce qu'on voit
malheureusement m alors je termine si
vous permettez et malheureusement ça
cache la réalité
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec le
gouvernement justement pour les familles
monoparentales une loi en est sorti on
attend cette loi qui a été décalée à
cause du coc vide
malheureusement moi aussi j'ai travaillé
dans ce sens là n est pas encore là je
le déplore aussi mais n'oublions pas
qu'il faut pas il faut pas cacher tous à
gâcher tout ça avec de la violence avec
de la radicalisation et être hors la loi
et pour moi je pense qu'on peut
manifester on peut faire crier sa colère
lorsqu'on est dans le cadre de la loi
après qu'on ait hors-la-loi on n'est
plus entendue
malheureusement et ça c'est dommage
chinois revenir sur ces points qui sont
importants mais je veux finir le tour de
table avec eux yann qui a répondu oui
j'ai répondu oui c'est parce que je
crois que la colère est intact mais le
mouvement des gilet jaune cours d'une
certaine manière à sa perte pour une
raison très simple qu'on peut voir
d'ailleurs dans l'histoire j'ai été
assez frappé de voir que souvent la
revendication historique des gilet jaune
s'était pas mai 68 c'est pas 1848 cité
la commune souvent je les ai vus donc je
me suis interrogé pourquoi pourquoi la
commune une raison simple si une colère
c'est veut dire ya vraiment quelque
chose qui ne passe plus dans ce pays les
gens ne se sentent plus tour présenté il
ya des gens vraiment en souffrance hier
j'ai pris un vtc la course était
tellement difficile
en plus de la
course que je devais payer avec mon
iphone j'ai donné 10 euros de pourboire
la personne la manière dont le chauffeur
m'a regardé pour me remercier était un
signe qui a vraiment des gens dans une
grande souffrance
alors moi je me sors de moi même parce
que je suis un privilégié je suis
écrivain j'ai une vie de rêve et je peux
vous dire quand même que ça force à
penser contre soi même le mouvement d'un
gilet jaune c'est bien sûr que c'est
agaçant tous les samedis que ça mais
c'est fait pour
heureusement que ça nous agace les
privilégiés et heureusement que ça nous
interrogent et heureusement qu'on les
trouve insupportable parce qu'à force je
veux bien entendre le message qu'on veut
peut-être pas entendre dit au début par
frilosité et par petite bourgeoisie tu
es aussi et 1800 110,6 la commune de
paris pourquoi eric je crois que ça
hérite des qualités qui sont la colère
mais aussi des défauts ce qui a mis fin
à la commune de paris
c'est le fait que le mouvement n'était
pas structuré blanqui qui aurait pu
peut-être comme jérôme rodriguez
incarner la commune était
malheureusement aubagne à l'époque il
n'a pas pu être là présent mais je crois
que ce qui manque c'est que des petits
îlots de personnalités qui veulent
récupérer le mouvement mais n'a aucune
qui sort complètement en 68e cohn-bendit
ses quarante mille morts la commune et
non mais non mais non la répression mais
c'est pas juste l'absence de
structuration mais ni jeudi à la
répression parce que le grand tabou des
sociétés d'aujourd'hui et heureusement
c'est la mort et on a déjà un nom mais
je continue juste il ya la première
chose c'est donc il n'y a pas de figure
qui rice matic gd gilet jaune sa
première chose d'eux mise à part michel
ont franchement non peut-être que c'est
celle qui émergent mais il voyait qu'il
émerge de manière négative
il est obligé d'émerger presque à son
corps défendant parce que c'est vrai que
perdre un oeil il ya deux mois mais
c'est non mais je peux terminer perdre
un oeil c'est pas rien donc il
mériterait d'être cette figure que
charismatique il le mérite mais à son
corps défendant
jérôme n'a jamais voulu être n'ont
jamais mené à son la deuxième chose
c'est que michel onfray mise à part il
n'y a pas de penseurs des dg des jaunes
ils ont pas de grands intellectuels avec
michel onfray mise à part et là est la
troisième chose que je voudrais dire sa
mesure batteur là bruno tu peux dire
mais salut salut si ni la troisième
l'objection youtube en ut avocats les
objections sur ont franchi il dit onfray
c'est un grand penseur très certainement
j'imagine mais un grand penseur c'est
parce qu'ils passent à la télé ou san
martin médéric mouvement veut dire aussi
si on pouvait arrêter les invectives
personnelles les trucs de cour de
récréation et de bac à sable machin dit
que là on essaye quand même d'avoir un
débat vous avez tourné aujourd'hui jeudi
eric j'ai dit qu'il ya par rapport aux
événements comme mai 68 où tous les
intellectuels français sont engouffrés
je trouve que les jets les jeux ne sont
pas soutenues par l'intelligentsia c'est
vrai voilà c'est ce que je dis et c'est
aussi ce qui leur manque dans leur
combat et c'est pour ça si quelques
scies des intellectuels pouvez les
ralliés de manière comme sartre qui
montait sur son tonneau en 1972 devant
les usines pour dire je suis avec vous
un grand talent et ça ça leur manque et
la troisième chose eric et ça on ne peut
peut-être que s'en réjouir qui pue la
garde nationale mais si aujourd'hui
avait la garde nationale comme l'ex aux
états unis je pense que la marche sur
l'elysée aurait déjà eu lieu
bel et bien